es ist ein abenteuer auf leben und tod
ich muss eine nacht in der wildnis
überstehen und das fast ohne hilfsmittel
für mich eine große herausforderung denn
ich kenne ich nur in einem dschungel aus
meiner heimatstadt berlin
wenn ich hier den weg nicht kenne schaue
ich einfach auf dem smartphone habe ich
hunger oder durst bestelle ich was
brauche ich kein problem
manchmal frage ich mich schon was will
ich eigentlich machen wenn ich ohne all
das hier zurecht kommen müssen noch in
der wildnis würde ich es schaffen auch
nur eine einzige nacht dort zu überleben
das will ich herausfinden mit sieben
weiteren stadtmenschen nehme ich in
thüringen an einem survival camp teil
überlebens trainer christoph weidner
bringt uns die tricks bei mit denen wir
in der wildnis bestehen können
survival beginnt im kopf das ist mehr
psycho als wirklich techniken
beherrschen und können und
überlebenswillen ist nicht antrainiert
war unsere erste aufgabe wir sollen in
zweiergruppen einen vorab vereinbarten
treffpunkt finden mein team partner
anthony ist auch zum ersten mal dabei
ich finde es macht einfach spaß man
kommt auch irgendwie mal raus und man
ist auch ein bisschen befreit also von
dem ganzen stress im dichten wald wird
es schwierig wie wir es heute morgen
gelernt haben versuchen wir uns am moos
bewuchs der bäume zu orientieren
man muss natürlich dann mehrere bäume
nehmen
man guckt das mosop nordwestlicher seite
wachsen aber ohne moos nix los wir
befragen sicherheitshalber den kompass
aber auch das ist ohne übung gar nicht
so einfach dass die navigations übung
heute morgen war ich ganz schön und gut
aber wenn man dann wirklich dabei ist
und den kompass in der hand hat und das
versucht herauszufinden wo man lang
gehen muss ich bin jetzt total
immerhin finden wir den treffpunkt ohne
uns groß zu verlaufen
hier werden wir unser nachtlager
aufschlagen und testen schon mal den
härtegrad des waldbodens
aus ersten bauen wir uns einen
unterschlupf der erste aha effekt mit
den elastischen kiefern wurzeln lassen
sich die erste gut verknoten
christoph weidner zeigt uns wie wir
unsere obdach stabil und wasserdicht
bauen können den first für unsere
konstruktion richten wir so aus dass die
öffnung zur windstillen richtung weist
dünne zweige und unmengen von laub
halten wasser ab und die wärme im
innenbereich
darum soll der schlafraum auf möglichst
kleinen und beschließen
aber man ist schon ach das geht voll
danach treibt uns der hunger wieder
weiter
du kannst diese frisch austreibenden
blätter von laubbäumen kannst du im
frühjahr essen aber gut schmecken tun
neben haselnuss knospen und hagebutten
ernte ich auch noch sauer kleben
aber satt wird man davon irgendwie nicht
doch wasser ist der e viel wichtiger
anfeuchten tal senken wie hier sollte
man sich auf die suche nach wasser
quellen machen wir haben eine gefunden
zugegeben mit hilfestellung für mich
eine schöne erkenntnis das wasser
sprudelt hier im trink walid einfach so
heraus schon super meint ebenso wichtig
feuer machen
dafür brauche ich einen kleinen stapel
zweige und als zünder birkenrinde denn
die ist er halt ich ich habe etwas von
der äußeren haut abkommen aber nicht
wohne spezialausrüstung weiter mit feuer
stahl kann ich durch reibung extrem
heiße funken erzeugt jahres geschafft
wenn auch nach vielen erfolglosen
versuchen aber endlich können wir die
würstchen grillen die unser trainer aus
mitleid über die magere sammle ausbeute
spendiert hat keiner soll mit schlechten
erinnerungen gehen also das hoffe ich
eigentlich am meisten
also das loch ich so diese das feuer
entfacht wird für für draußen zeigen
wieder
ich habe jetzt auch keine andere wahl
als draußen zu sein nun wartet die
letzte herausforderung übernachten im
dunklen wald
acht uhr morgens ich werde von
vogelgezwitscher geweckt
ganz bequem war die nacht zwar nicht
aber trotz temperaturen im einstelligen
bereich habe ich nicht gefroren
also es war eine tolle erfahrung aber
jetzt bin ich echt ganz schön kaputt
ich war überrascht wie schnell ist
funktioniert sich einen unterschlupf zu
wahren und wie schwer es ist feuer zu
machen aber jetzt freue ich mich vor
allem auf eine magische und ein leckeres
leckeres behandelt essen also schnell
weg hier
aber was will ich mehr ich habe überlebt
und komme bestimmt bald mal wieder
zurück in die natur
[Musik]